you have your day jobs and you know that
there's a relationship kind of an
adversarial relationship between what
you're doing for money and what you want
to do for love
what are some of the worst day jobs
you've had oh man let me start by
telling you one of one of my best day
jobs just because there's such a good
life hack when I first came to Hollywood
I took a job as a temp typist so I know
how to type
they brought me into a on a some office
somewhere and this is in the early days
of computers and they said do you know
how to use Word Perfect now up until
that moment in my life I had never heard
the words word perfect but these are the
words that came out of my mouth it's
been a while give me the manual and I'll
refresh my memory and I realized that
that that strategy is one I use a lot I
if I don't know how to do something I
will fake that I know how to do it
shamelessly happily uh because I usually
can pull it off I have confidence I'm
not faking brain surgery I'm faking you
know we're perfect it's not the end of
the world I did teach archery and
sailing and I didn't know how to do
either of those things so that was
problematic but nobody got hurt
the the first worst job I had was as an
advertising copywriter my first job out
of college I got a job that was a big
challenge for me because there was no
creativity in it and I wanted there to
be I was a copywriter I'm supposed to do
what the client wants and the client
wants the headline to be uh
spring sale that's what the headline
needs to be you know not spring into
sale or whatever else I think is funny
I had a couple of jobs I got fired out
of that job because they knew I wasn't
right for it and I didn't know I wasn't
right for it so they did me a favor by
firing me my next job was also in
advertising and that was bad in a
different way because they loved me and
they offered me the moon they said you
can be a creative director here in no
time at all you can be a star and and I
realized I was 25 and I said if I if I
go down this road I'm going to wake up
when I'm 40 feeling like I made the
world safe for advertising and that is
not the destiny I want so I quit that
job and I quit it to become a creative
entrepreneur so really from the age of
I haven't had much of what you would
call day jobs I've had a succession of
hustles staff assignments you know
script assignments whatnot
I spent a cup of coffee on staff at
Charles in Charge that was a bad job for
me
because I was too insecure I hadn't yet
figured out how to manage my insecurity
I suffered a lot on that job I suffered
because I wasn't getting validation and
wasn't getting approval and they didn't
bring me back and and they were right
not to do so
I find that the jobs that that I have
considered to be bad jobs the ones where
it hasn't been a good fit between what I
can do and what is required of me
but I scooped ice cream in high school
I sold stereo in college that wasn't a
bad job
uh
I taught a lot but I love to teach so
that's not really a bad job
I thought I had a bad job when I started
doing educational Consulting because I
thought I was moving away from my path
I thought okay clearly I got to go after
this because it's sick billable hours
the the clientele that I have is an
educational consultant these are people
who are trying to get into top Business
Schools and they're paying top dollar
for my service happens that I didn't
realize I had a lot to offer them I also
didn't realize I was going to learn so
much about how to be a stand-up comic by
teaching them how to be a good
interviewer and then I was going to turn
around and help them interview better by
what I learned from stand-up comedy
I am
uh
I'm a polymath I go off in all different
directions I have never had a day job
that stunted me for long because
either I figured out or they figured out
that I was in the wrong place
I often fantasized about what I called
the
vacation of nine to five
knee-jerkmentation
I wanted a job that I didn't have to
think about I could just put in my time
and do my thing
it it was not to be
because there's something in my nature
that says I'm really only comfortable in
groups that I'm leading
and now that I know that about myself I
stay out of situations that that are not
right for me also I figured out early on
if you're an employee you can be fired
or laid off your destiny is not your own
and it was clear to me that I wanted
that so I think I come at your question
from a different
point of view than most
people in this audience
you have your day jobs and you know that
there's a relationship kind of an
adversarial relationship between what
you're doing for money and what you want
to do for love and we can describe this
as the difference between hard work and
hustle hard work is what you do at the
job it's hard it's work you do it hustle
is what you invest in your own self and
your own goals
and my sense of it is that if you can
apply the same
professionalism and showing up on time
and doing your job that is required of
most day jobs
to your creative aspiration if you can
be as diligent in your side hustle if
you as diligent in your art as you are
diligent in your paycheck then you can
Thrive creatively
but let's not make a mistake at the end
of the day you might have to take a step
off a cliff you might have to be like
the fool in the Tarot deck who stands on
the precipice on a cliff with one foot
off into space
he's holding a flower in one hand that
represents Beauty he's looking off into
the sky where there's a sun and an
infinity symbol
and his understanding is if I take this
step forward into the void I'm not going
to fall I'm going to fly and that's what
he does so
if I can speak from my heart to your
heart they're in the audience I would
say this
you stand on the edge of a cliff and you
want to step off
step off you'll never fall you'll fly
what are your thoughts on balancing life
between having a day job and being an
artist
I addressed this question early on when
I was teaching a class how to break into
Hollywood
it occurred to me that I needed to
divide my time into thirds
one third of my time needed to go to put
money in my pocket
body keeping the body working
one third of my time had to go to my
mind that was my creative aspiration my
work the work that I wanted to do and
one third of my time needed to go to my
spirit and that would be Recreation
friends relationships love
Sports Athletics Ultimate Frisbee that's
where my passion lies
and so I was just very practical about
it I said I'm gonna I'm gonna look for
work but I'm not gonna let it take up
too much of my time
and then I'm gonna be diligent in my
practice I'm going to make time for my
work and then I'm going to be generous
in my Recreation because I know that my
Recreation is a valid required part of
this
when you get down under the hood of this
question you see that there is a hidden
conspiracy at work it's the conspiracy
between interfere and outer reality let
me tell you what I mean
if my work and creativity are not
balanced in the sense that my work is
dominating and my creativity is
suffocating
I'm likely carrying this attitude with
me home from work every day
ah I just worked all day I I have
engaged my brain I earned some money I
have been working I am excused from not
working now
I'm tired from working so I'm just going
to veg out on the couch this is what's
happening on the text level but on the
subtext level it's a little bit more
devious because there's part of me that
never wants to do the creativity The
Fear Part fear is always present in the
creative process and when you are early
or young in your process fear dominates
and fear is sneaky fear tells you you
worked hard all day you can afford to
Goof Off
because fear is actually instructing you
not to engage with the work because fear
doesn't want to be afraid
so fear will say fear will make excuses
you've worked plenty you don't have to
work anymore your mother wants to see
you go see your mother your friends want
you oh that movie sounds so great but
all you're really doing is making
excuses for not engaging with your
practice
people face practical circumstances they
might need to give 40 hours a week to
their job in which case they need to say
to themselves
my creativity exists in the corners of
my time I know that now my job is to
expand the corners
find Corners use the corners recognize
that fear might keep me from going there
and just try to go there anyhow and then
I'll use tricks I remember using this
one a lot when I was trying to get my
writing going and struggling like you do
I said to myself I'm going to wait to
write until 15 minutes before I know I
have to leave to go somewhere and that
way when I sit down to write I know it's
only going to be for 15 minutes so it
doesn't scare me because how much damage
can I do to myself how much negativity
can I generate negative self-image can I
generate in only 15 minutes of bad
writing and that 15 minutes turned into
20 turned into 25 turned into 30. that's
how I put more time and effort into my
practice
as I worked for more sophisticated ways
to cut down on the time I wasn't
spending in practice I will tell you
that the secret
to this share the secret
if you're selling your time and only
your time you can't really get ahead
because you're selling something that
doesn't have added value
you're selling something that everybody
has and you're competing against other
people who have the same thing to sell
like you can go and stand in a shoe
store for eight hours a day well I had I
sold shoes for a while that was a bad
job as a college job summer camp
counselor that was another bad job now
that I remember
I figured out
and if I could sell added value I could
sell my time at a much higher rate
I'm not working for minimum wage
competing against other people who are
working for minimum wage
I'm doing something they can't do so I
can charge more for it
and boy was I
strategic about this I'll give you the
the inciting incident and some
manifestation
I had quit my job as an advertising
copywriter and I was being a
singer-songwriter and I was hustling for
gigs any kind of gig it didn't have to
be a singer-songwriter just whatever I
needed to put
money in my pocket sign out in the
newspaper
remember newspapers kids find out a
wanted Santa Claus on stilts this was a
Friday afternoon
said to myself Santa Claus call the guy
up said I heard you're looking for Santa
Claus on stilts he said do you walk on
stilts
I said when do you need me to start he
said Monday I said I'll be there I never
said I walked on stilts I said to myself
I got the weekend to learn that's plenty
of time how hard can it be
but it paid thirty dollars an hour in
1982. chunk of change when I came out to
Hollywood in 85
I brought with me the experience of
booking myself into fairs and festivals
not just singing and playing guitar but
painting faces uh uh strolling uh
ventriloquism act all kinds of I did the
strolling Punk folk Troubadour where I
dressed having Punk and half in folk
made up songs on the spot whatever
when I came to California looking to be
a writer and knowing that I couldn't
give away my time cheaply I started
calling Rolodex calling every shopping
mall in Southern California and building
relationships with uh marketing
directors and selling myself into
shopping malls as a strolling
Entertainer a mime a ventriloquist a
juggler
special for holidays you know Cupid for
Valentine's Day oh oh and Bob the left
another now that's it how do I know I
love the leprechaun George you know here
on St Patrick's Day to entertain you I
could earn a hundred dollars an hour
doing that and my wife's working as a
mime she can earn a hundred dollars an
hour on the same gig so we're pulling
600 out of three hours worth of work in
1985. win and need full-time jobs we
found a way to level up the value at
what we were doing So for anybody who's
looking for a way out of the Trap of a
nine to five job the place to start is
to ask what can I do better than anybody
else and how can I make that pay
all of which is by way of saying it's
considerably harder now than it was when
I was younger because the
the competition not just the number of
competitors but the price competition if
I want to sell a novel I'm competing
against everybody who's willing to give
their novel away just because they're
desperate for somebody to read it how
can I as a as a purveyor of literary
fiction make a living in a world where
people can read through a thousand
lifetimes for free books on the internet
and never run out of material just on
the Gutenberg project
so it's really really hard now in some
senses it's easy streaming media makes
things more accessible to writers of
scripts and do it yourself makes it
accessible to everybody in ways that
that that weren't I imagine if I were me
but young now I'd be all over Instagram
and Tick Tock and and probably just
saying probably nobody's ever going to
watch this but what the heck it's
something I can do now let's do it and
see what happens I'm fond of the
following expression throw it out the
window and see if it lands
chances are it will